- [Instructor] We are told a pig runs
rightward 20 meters to eat a juicy apple.
It then walks leftward five meters
to eat a nut.
Finally it walks leftward
another 25 meters
to eat another nut.
The total time taken by the pig
was 300 seconds.
What was the pig's average velocity
and average speed over this time?
And assume rightwards is positive
and leftwards is negative
and round your answer to
two significant digits.
So, pause this video
and try to work it out
on your own.
All right, now let's do this together
and first let's just draw a diagram
of what is going on.
So, this is our pig.
It first runs rightward 20 meters,
so we could say that's a
positive 20-meter displacement,
so it goes plus 20 meters,
ends up right over there.
Then it walks leftwards five meters,
so then from there
it's gonna walk leftwards five meters,
so we could call that a
negative five-meter displacement
and then finally, it walks
leftward another 25 meters.
So, then it walks leftward
another 25 meters,
so it gets right over there,
so that would be a displacement
of negative 25 meters to eat another nut,
so it ends up right over there.
Now, to figure out our average velocity,
let me write it down,
so our velocity average
and even this is one dimensional,
it is a vector, it has direction to it.
We specify the direction with the sign
positive being rightwards being positive
and leftwards being negative.
You oftentimes for one-dimensional vectors
might not see an arrow there
or might not see it bolded
and just written like this.
But our average velocity
is going to be equal
to, you could view it as our displacement
or our change in X
divided by how much time
has actually lapsed
and so, what is our
displacement going to be?
What's it?
We have plus 20 meters
and then we have minus five meters
and then we go to the
left another 25 meters,
minus 25 meters
and then all of that is going
to over the elapsed change
or change in time,
all of that is over 300 seconds.
So, what is this numerator going to be?
This is 20 minus 30,
so that's gonna be equal to negative 10,
so this is equal to negative 10 meters
over 300 seconds.
So, the average velocity
is going to be equal to
negative 1/30 meters per second,
the negative specifies that on average
the velocity is towards the left.
If you wanna specify this as a decimal
with two significant digits,
this is going to be,
so this will approximately equal to 0.033.
That would be 1/30.
Now let's try to tackle average speed.
So, our speed,
R sometimes is used for speed, R for rate,
our average speed
is not going to be our displacement
divided by our lapsed time,
it is going to be our distance
divided by our elapsed time
and we'll see that these are
not going to be the same thing.
That's one of the points of this problem,
so our distance divided
by our lapsed time.
So, what's our distance traveled?
Well, it's gonna be the absolute value
of each of these numbers,
so it's gonna be 20 meters
plus five meters plus 25 meters.
Notice, there's a difference here.
We're not subtracting the five and the 25,
we're just adding all of that.
We just care about the magnitudes.
Divided by 300 seconds
and so, this is going to
be equal to 50 meters,
over 300 seconds
which is equal to five over 30
which is equal to 1/6
of a meter per second
and if we want to write it as a decimal,
let's see, six goes into one,
let's put some zeros here,
six goes into 10 one time,
one times six is six,
I can scroll down a little bit
and then we subtract, we get a four,
six goes into 40 six times,
six times six is 36
and then we get,
let me just scroll down
a little bit more again
and then we get another four
and then we're just gonna
keep getting sixes over here,
so this is gonna be
approximately equal to 0.1,
if we want two significant digits,
17 meters per second
and we are done.
We figured out the average velocity
and the average speed.